ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูป๊า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดี
ค่ะก็ก็มาเจอกับเรา 2 คนอีกแล้วหนอในช่วง
องค์ไม่ใช่วีดีโอนี้เป็นระดับอะไรคะครูบา
ระวีดีโอนี้เป็นระดับบีกินเนอร์ค่ะค่ะใช่
แล้วบีกินเนอร์นอนเดี๋ยวก็ก็เรามาเริ่ม
กันจากว่าวันนี้วันอะไรคะครูป๊า
วันนี้วัน
พุธค่ะใส่ซ้ำพุธ
วันพุธที่เท่าไหร่คะครูฟ้าวันพุธที่ 22
ค่ะดี 12 เดือน
เดือนธันวาคมเดือนธันวาคมเป็นเดือนที่
เท่าไหร่คะเดือนธันวาคมเป็นเดือนที่ 10
อ๋อค่ะดีผชอะไรคะดีผช
2564 ปีคศ
2  021
แล้วเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไร
เมื่อวานนี้วันอังคารค่ะวันอังคารวัน
อังคารที่เท่าไหร่คะวันอังคารที่ 21
เดือน
เดือนธันวาคมเป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะเป็น
เดือนที่ 12 ค่ะปีพต
2564 ที่คศ 2  021
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันพุธวัน
พฤหัสบดีอยากได้วันพฤหัสบดีวันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันที่ 23 ค่ะเดือนละคือว่าคมเป็น
เดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะเป็นเดือนที่ 12 ค่ะปี
พตตปีพศ 2564 ปีค.ศเต๊ตปีค.ศ 2002  1 ขาด
วันที่ก็เป็นวันพุธแล้วเนาะแล้วตอนนี้ตอน
นี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา
5:00 น 5:00 กี่นาทีคะ
05:31 นาทีค่ะ
05:31 นาทีแล้วหนอสาก็เป็นตอนเย็น 5 โมง
31 ตอนเย็นเนาะใส่แล้ววันนี้นะคะคุณฟ้า
โทษ
เราสองคนก็จะมาแข่งกันอีกแล้วค่ะมีเกม
สีห้องจ่ายว่าครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าเนี่ยใครก็
ต้องคิดคิดๆได้เร็วกว่ากันหรือว่าเยอะ
กว่ากัน
เต้นตื่นเต้นสมัยอ่ะ
ว่าเกมวันนี้ของเรานะคะก็จะเกี่ยวค่ะที่
นี่ฮ่ะภูฟ้า
อะไรอะไรคะตู้เย็น
ตึก
ตึกตึกเนี่ยเหมือนอพานเม้นคนดีกิน
งูออฟฟิศยูเวนเกอร์ไม่ใช่ reacher เรน
เจอร์อันนี้มันตื่นเครื่องหมายเหมือนไทเป
ก็ failure ที่ไหนอีกแล้วคะตึก
ใบหยกกลยกเออสุดมหานคร Building
เอ้อใช่ไหมคะแต่ว่าตึกอันนี้เนี่ยมันคือ
โรง
หมอพยาบาลค่ะคุณป๊าใช่ไหม
ใช่โรงพยาบาลใช้เวลาที่เราไม่สบายนะ
เจ็บของเราไปโรงพยาบาลโรงพยาบาลแล้วที่
โรงพยาบาลมีอะไรบ้างคะนั่นแหละค่ะเวลาที่
ครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าเนี่ยไปโรงพยาบาลหญิง
เห็นผู้หญิงนั้นอินตาใช่ไหมคะ
มีตาเนี่ย
เห็นอะไรบ้างครูฟ้าเห็นอะไรบ้างที่ออกมา
ยาบาล
เราจะมาแข่งกันเถอะกูวาดรูปหรอได้เลยค่ะ
วาดรูปสวยเหมือนผู้หญิงว่าตึกแป้งเราจะ
ไม่ได้ว่าที่นี่นะที่กระดานอันนี้ไม่ใช่
ไวท์บอร์ดนี้เราจะวาดที่ Screen แต่ผู้
หญิงจะ Share  screen แล้วเราก็จะแข่งกัน
ช้า Share  screen ก่อนนะคะ
ไวท์บอร์ดเนาะ
นี่ค่า
โอเคครูฟ้า
อะไรคะเห็น screen แล้วใช่ไหมคะเห็น
screen แล้วอ่ะ
เห็นไหมว่ากูหญิงกดแล้วมันมีสีขึ้นมาเห็น
ไหมไหนอ่ะที่แบบมีสีขาวอะไรเงี้ยพ่อแม่
ไม่เห็นน้องโอเกะครูผู้หญิงเนี่ยครูฟ้าจะ
เขียนสีอะไรคะสีเหลือง
เหลืองสีเหลืองโอเคผู้หญิงศรีผู้หญิงสี
ฟ้านี้นะคะหัวใจสีฟ้าผู้หญิงต้องเขียน
ด้วยสีฟ้าว่าสีเหลืองจ้าโอเคค่ะๆให้ครู
ฟ้าก่อนแล้วกันเวลาที่เราไปขี้อยู่โรง
พยาบาล
กี่โมงพี่โทรโรงพยาบาลนะคะเราเห็นอะไร
บ้างมีอะไรอยู่ที่โรงพยาบาลฉันต้องแบ่ง
ไหมไม่ใช่มั้ยโอเคตรงวะ
เอ่อตกอยู่ดีไม่เป็นไรคะตรงนี้ก็คือหญิง 5
หญิง
หญิงเขียนแล้วนะรอสักครู่นะคะนี่ไง
อันนี้ฟ้า
โอเคอ่าครูฟ้าเริ่มก่อนเลยค่ะโอเค
โรงพยาบาลก็ต้องนี้มี
มีอะไร
เตียง
อ้า
เตียงยัง
โรงพยาบาลก็ต้องมี
มีอะไรผู้หญิงจะว่ายากหน่อยนะ
อะไรก็ได้
คุณหมออ๋อค่ะ
โฮปอ๋อ
คุณหมออยากให้คุณหมอ
เวลาที่เรา Face สบายเราก็ต้องไปหาคุณหมอ
เลยคุณหมอก็จะบอกก็ไม่สบายน้องมีคุณหมอ
อ่ะ
งั้นครูฟ้าเนาะใส่มีอะไรเปล่าเอาอะไรดีมี
อันนี้อะไรคะ
อะไรอ่ะคะ
น้องเกลือออกขอ
เมื่อวานก็มีอันนี้ค่ะอะไรคะผู้หญิง
นี้
รถพยาบาล
เป็นไงเนี่ยอ๋อใช่ไหมรถพยาบาลน่าจะมีที่
นี่ใช่ไหมแล้วต้องติงจิงจิงนะอะไรนั้นปี
บ่ B บ่บีบอกพี่บอกรถพยาบาลค่ะ
ครูฟ้าล่ะครูฟ้าหรอคิดๆก็มีอะไรอีกเออโรง
พยาบาล
ไม่ใช่อันนี้คิดนี่ไงอะไรคะยังไม่เขียน
ไม่ติดนี่อณิ
ยาเอาก็อย่าใช่ไหมกิน
อ่ะโรงพยาบาลก็ต้องเรียนให้ข้าวว่าอย่า
จังอะไรคะรถเข็นค่ะอ่ะ
รอเดี๋ยวนะไม่เสร็จ
แล้วก็จะมีล้อ
ล้อ
สายเรานี้เป็นร้อ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ถ้าเหนื่อยก็มี
คอมพิวเตอร์ค่ะแล้วก็ที่นี่ก็จะมีเมาใช่
ไหมโรงพยาบาล
มีคอมพิวเตอร์
คอมพิวเตอร์ค่ะ
ของครูฟ้า
โรงพยาบาลเบอร์ต้องมี
เก้าอี้
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ติดกันนะ
เก้าอี้
r9 อี้นะคะโอเค
ของครูหญิงค่ะโรงพยาบาลก็ต้องมีคุณหมอ
แล้วใช่ไหม
ตี
พยาบาล
[เพลง]
ใช่มั้ยพยาบาลพยาบาลก็จะมีมั่ว
ใช่ไหมคะมีอาหมอแล้วก็มีพยาบาล
[เพลง]
ของครูฟ้านี่เลย
อะไรคะนะ
อ๋ออ๋อห้องฉุกเฉิน
จ่ายห้องสุขเฉยๆค่ะถูกต้อง
อ่ะของครูหญิงนะคะมีคุณหมอมีพยาบาลแล้วก็
ต้องมีคนไม่สบาย
คนไม่สบาย
เห็นผู้ชายนอนหรือว่าผู้หญิงหาขาทีมอะ
ไม่สบายนะคนป่วยนะเราเรียกว่าคนป่วยนะคะ
[เพลง]
ครูป๋าค่ะนี่ค่ะ
เขียนไม่ติดอ่ะมา
ทั้งหมดสิไว้ว่ามันไม่ออกเลยออกมาไปโดน
อ๋อ
นี้ไม่ใช่ Google นะคะ
ขึ้นเหมือนกันเลยครับ
มีดผ่าตัดแผลมีถาดอัดนิดเป๊กหรอ
ของครูหญิงนะคะก็จะเป็นถุงค่ะถุงอะไรคะ
ถุงเลือดเดี๋ยวถ่ายอันนี้ใช่ไหมเขาจะมี
เหมือน scale เซลล์ใช่ไหมคะว่าจะเป็นสาย
ตอนนี้ก็จะมีเลือดนี่เนาะน่ากลัวนิดนึงนะ
คะไม่รู้นะเกรงกลัวเรื่องหรือเปล่าจะให้
ดูนะคะถุงเลือดเนอะแล้วจะมองเห็นถุงเลือด
สมัยเวลาหรอกภาพมีเลือดออกมานะ Group เอง
a3i  Group  B  Group
เบอร์โทรแล้วก็
EB นะคะนี่คือถุงเลือดนักมีส่งเลือดที่
โรงพยาบาล
ของผู้ฟ้าเนี่ย
แม้ค่ะอุ้ย
กู
[เพลง]
ไม่
ให้คิดได้ยังไงก็ได้ของอะไรฟ้ามีนี่ใช่
มั้ยมีมีปี้นะคะผู้หญิงก็มีกรรไกรค่ะ
กรรไกร
กรรไกรนะกรรไกร
ฟ้ามีอันนี้
เค้า
อาจจะท้อกดผิด
แค่รหัสน้ำมันลบลบใจอ่ะโอเคอะไรอ่ะครูฟ้า
ค่ะผู้เขาเหรอคะเดี๋ยว
เขา
อ้าอันนี้เลยเล่นๆ
วันไม่ติดแล้วอ่ะเดี๋ยวนะ
อาจติดอยู่กับอะไรอ่ะ
ที่ให้ออกซิเจนออที่คอดที่นี่
เออที่คลอง 7 โอเค
ของครูหิงค์ดี
สำลีค่ะ
สำลีให้ดูลูกเนาะนี่
ไม่ได้จะเข้าใจใช่ไหมก็ดู
นี่นะคะสำลีเนาะเอาสำลีสีขาวๆนะคะมีสำลี
ค่ะ
จะครูฝาง
ของครูฟ้ามีนี่ค่ะ
อะไรเอ่ยไอ้ดูเล็กๆต่อไม่เล็กแล้ว
ใหญ่อยู่
เราก็ Hall
ต่อกับฮอล้างแผล
เวลาแบบนะคะ
ของครูหญิงค่ะมีสำลีแล้วก็จะมีเป็น
ผ้าก็อตอะ
เสื้อผ้าก๊อตทา God ใช่ไหมเวลาเวลาแผล
ด้วยแอลกอฮอล์ก็จะมีเป็นไข่เนาะ
ใช่ไหม
อันนี้นะคะอันนี้ถ้าก็อตนอนสำลีอันนี้ผ้า
ก๊อตนะคะ
ครูฝาอ่าไฟฟ้ามีนี่ฮะ
อะไรคะ
อะไรอ่ะ
เลื่อย
เทียนซ.
โรงพยาบาลด้วยเหรอคะโรงพยาบาลมีเรื่อยค่ะ
เรื่อยตัดกระดูกโห
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
เรื่อยๆเวลาแบบว่านักเรียนคุณหมอ 100
ล้าน in เรื่อยเอาไว้เวลาแบบอันนี้อ่ะ
เนาะกระดูกกระดูก
ทำไมวะ
มันก็ถูกเออ
แต่เขาผู้หญิงไม่ใช่กระดูกแล้วค่ะ
ของผู้หญิงมีอันนี้ค่ะ
อะไหล่ห้อง
อันนี้เป็น
m.r.i.
เครื่อง MRI น้องนักเรียนก็เราก็จะไปนอน
อยู่ในนี้นะคะ
นะเครื่อง MRI
ของครูฟ้ามีหนี้
อะไรค่ะสู่ป่า
เครื่องวัดชีพจรหรือ
ก็
จะไปใส่เออ
เช็คหัวใจ
ชายไหมเรื่องวัด
ชีพจรจุด
อะของครูหญิงค่ะ
มันเป็นยังไงหว่า
ค่า
เครื่องยิงอุณหภูมิใช่ไหมคะใส่เขาจะมี
เครื่องอันนี้เนาะเนี่ยนะเครื่องที่กู
หญิงวงกลมไว้นะคะนักเรียนแล้วก็ใส่ไปที่
หูแล้วก็แล้วก็จะเช็คก็
37 องศาอ่าโอเค
เครื่องวัดอุณหภูมิน้องอันนี้นะคะ
ลูกค้าหมีนี่
อะไรคะองศาค
ตัว
อะไรอ่ะหัวใจมีหัวใจจริงๆ
นะยังต้องวาดแบบนี้โรงเรียนอาจจะเก็บมหา
ธวัชแผนมันจะไม่เจ็บ
หัวใจหัวใจ
หัวใจ
น่ากลัวของลิงอีก 1 อันหรอไม่รู้จะว่าถูก
หรือเปล่าอ้ะ
มันจะเป็นอันนี้เนาะเราก็มีสายแล้วก็จะมี
หน้าจอ
ใช่ไหมหน้าจอนิอ่าอันนี้ก็จะเป็นใครลูก
ลื่นแล้วก็จะมีเจลแล้วเรียกว่าเครื่อง
เอกซเรย์ชนิด
เองเรารูปก็จะอยู่ที่นี่ก็จะมีรูป
สมัยมีโรคนะ Baby เนี่ยเหมือนอันรักเมื่อ
เช้าออกไปเจ้ากะเรื่องอัตราสาวเป็น
เรื่องอัลตร้าซาวด์
สาว
[เพลง]
จะให้ของทรูฟ้าที่ได้มาอีก 1 อันที่ 1
อันแล้วฮะงั้นก็เอาอันนี้ค่ะค่ะ
เอาตรงนี้แล้วกันใกล้ๆฟ้าเลย
หาอะไรคะ
เงิน
มันคอมพิวเตอร์ใช่ไหม
เงินต้องมีเงินนะฮะโรงพยาบาล
นี่เนาะเดี๋ยวเรามาดูว่าของครูหญิงใช่ไหม
มีอะไรบ้างจะมาผิดบอกว่ามี
มีคุณหมออ๋อมีพยาบาลมีคนป่วยนะคะมีอันที่
สี่ทั้งสี่ก็รถเข็นหรอคะถ้ารถพยาบาล
ม 6 คอมพิวเตอร์
7 ถุงเลือดนะคะ 8 กรรไกร
9 สำลี 10 พาดอ๊อดเนาะ 11 เครื่อง MRI
นะคะ 12 เครื่องวัดอุณหภูมิแล้วก็ 13
เครื่องอัลตร้าซาวด์นี้ของครูหญิงนะแล้ว
ของครูฟ้าและมีอะไรบ้างของครูฟ้ามีนี่ค่ะ
อะไรคะเนี่ย 1
เตียง
ห่า
หรือยังมะฮะนอนนะสอง
เก้าอี้ค่ะ
3 สายน้ำเกลือค่ะเอาน้องเกลือนะคะ
4G อัลกอฮอลค่ะค่ายา 6
เอามีดค่ะ
7 เข็มฉีดยา
8 หน้ากากอนามัย
ใส่
มาสนะ 9 ห้องฉุกเฉินฉ่า
คลิป
หน้ากากออกซิเจน
11 เรื่อยๆ
หรือเห็นต่อ Man นะ
12 หัวใจ
เครื่องวัดชีพจร
เครื่องวัดที่ประจร 14 เงิน 14 เงินนะจอ
จริงมีอีกเยอะๆนะคะมีอีกเยอะๆน้องแต่ว่า
อันนี้ก็เป็นที่เราเห็นนะนักเรียนคิดว่า
ถ้ามีอะไรอีกก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้นะคะสาย
ค่ะวันนี้เราสองคนก็ต้องไปก่อนนะแล้วเจอ
กันใหม่วิดีโอหน้านะคะบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะ
วันนี้ค่าา